what's your favorite thing about her
her left oh that's really cute actually
i feel like she's going to watch this
yeah hey addison
when i went to the hype house i talked
to addison ray
about your guys's friendship
relationship
at the time she said that you guys had
spent a lot of time together i'm sure
you've seen this have you seen this
we were talking and like kind of on and
off just like trying to figure things
out and like i'm also like like i said
very new to this and like he's been in
this industry for a really long time
but um we just you know things happen
and then like we just decided like
we're better off as friends for now are
you guys together
now no comment but i feel like you guys
are hanging out a lot
we are hanging out we're hanging out
we're still like really good friends
like we've
i mean like we never broke and we never
separated for
like real bad reasons you know
like we were just busy um doing our own
things
uh now with quarantine
not so busy not saying anything but like
i'm just saying like
we're friends we're really good friends
well as a good friend since that's what
you
you say that you guys are is it nice to
have someone like her
in your life just because you sort of
came up at the same time and you
probably understand what one another
is is going through oh for sure yeah
yeah yeah do you guys talk about that
kind of stuff can you
yeah we thought we actually have like a
lot of deep talks about it
it's actually crazy like how big both of
us
got in such a short amount of time and
it's like we always like reflect saying
wow it's like so crazy
[Music]
what do you make of all the fans who so
hardcore ship you guys
together have hope my friends no i'm
kidding
have hope well i mean it does sound like
quarantine did kind of bring you guys
back together is that yeah i know we've
been hanging a lot
hanging out a lot recently okay what
what's your favorite thing about her
her left oh that's really cute actually
i feel like she's gonna watch this yeah
hey addison
i mean i feel fine i just cry myself to
sleep every night
yeah that's totally normal what do you
think of her videos with kourtney
kardashian
when the heck did she start hanging out
with the kardashians i
right you guys really are that big
though like the kardashians are trying
i'm not hanging out with the kardashians
i'm not
that you haven't gotten invited yet yeah
no i'm i'm waiting for hey kylie
what's up i'm waiting for a party invite
[Music]
well there have been a lot of tick-tock
breakups
and makeups in general so first of all
what did you make of josh
and nessa's split they're still they're
still
friendly so i mean like uh the the
difference between a lot of
relationships and them
is that like they are genuinely still
friends
so i respect that with other
relationships they split they talk crap
on social media
and it gets just blown way out of
proportion i think they handled the
breakup very well
do you think they'll get back together
yes
ah okay josh josh is
josh is a little simp
wait kind of like you and addison are
going to get back together oh
okay you brought that one in there
i have i have hope what about kyo and
olivia
i don't know that's a different story i
don't know but i can talk about that
do you feel like tick tock blew up
when people started shipping i mean i
think about like even charlie and lil
hoddy
initially do you think that was a big
part in
um your guys's platforms getting big is
seeing who you guys were dating and like
feel so invested in the personal lives
i think that had a huge
it was definitely a huge factor
especially because there was like
the hype girls and then the hype guys
getting in relationships it's not like a
hype girl
did like a a random like person it was
just like they're
another huge tick tocker i think that
like drove a lot of traffic to it i
think also when dancing
when the platform became like a dancing
app
that's when it also blew up it turned
into like a trailer
almost he doesn't even do youtube and
he's roasting me for doing tic tac i
don't even know how to do the renegade
what's the next youtube video that we
can expect from you
um the one that's coming out on
wednesday or thursday
is a video with addison so it is a video
with addison
yeah what can you tease chapstick does
that mean
is there a kissing in the video
chapstick that's all i'm gonna say
i'll ask you this then what is it like
to work with her
you know we've been doing i mean like
we've been
filming content together since november
october
october november of 2019 like we we
already broke the ice
like and like we're comfortable filming
together it's like
it's very easy like some people it's
like super hard to film with because
it's like oh i don't know you that well
like what are my boundaries
what can i joke about but like that's
very comfortable
i it is funny to watch your face because
you always smile when you talk about her
stop it you do look at that that's cute
come on okay well the fans will have
hope
if you guys do officially get back
together would there would that be some
sort of statement that you would make
publicly oh yeah so we should expect
maybe like an instagram post
or wednesday's video yeah you'll see in
the future maybe